foreign
press release from March 23rd World
Athletics Council decides on Russia
Belarus and female eligibility so I'm
going to scroll down hopefully not make
you guys dizzy here until we get to
transgender and DSD regulations DSD
stands for traditionally disorders of
sexual development they're calling it
um
they've used differences of sexual
development for DSD athletes the new
regulations will require any relevant
athletes to reduce their testosterone
levels below a limit of 2.5 that's going
to be nanomoles per liter I think for a
minimum of 24 months to compete
internationally in the female category
in any event not just the events that
were restricted under the previous
regulations cool not the focus here but
I wanted to read that to indicate that
the world Athletics Council has
discriminated between has differentiated
between people with dsds intersex
individuals in the older nomenclature
and trans people okay so what follows
then is not about intersex people not
about people with differences if you
will of sexual development but trans
people in regard to transgender athletes
the press release continues the council
has agreed to exclude male to female
transgender athletes who have been
through male puberty from female world
rankings competition from 31st of March
2023 how yeah okay it's about
time in these circumstances they
continue the council decided to
prioritize fairness and the Integrity of
the female competition before inclusion
exactly as they should have
finally World Athletics president
Sebastian Co said quote decisions are
always difficult when they involve
conflicting needs and rights between
different groups but we continue to take
the view that we must maintain fairness
for female athletes above all other
considerations we will be guided in this
by the science around physical
performance and male Advantage which
will inevitably develop over the coming
years as more evidence becomes available
we will review our position but we
believe the Integrity of the female
category in athletics is Paramount wow
amazing right so if I may have my screen
back
um
of course outfits like Stonewall UK are
decrying this as um as
closing the door and trans women
competing well no it doesn't
you can compete against members of your
birth sex if you are a trans woman what
it does is it closes the door and trans
women cheating which is different right
uh we aren't supposed to in sport allow
people to cheat and that's what the
rules are for so this is finally an
organization that has great reach at the
international level saying actually you
know what we're not going to continue to
allow cheating thank you very much we've
considered it and inclusion is not our
highest value fairness in sport is so
amazing I really hope this stands and
that we continue to see Domino's fall as
a result of this yes and uh tremendously
important that they distinguish between
intersex yes and I believe they did the
right thing there where they have to
make an arbitrary threshold they do but
they pick the threshold and you know let
the chips fall where they may
the question actually
is is this an anomalous case of an
organization making the right choice and
there will of course be tremendous
pushback and maybe they you know uh
Buckle right or does this signal the
beginning of an outbreak of reason on
this topic where the next thing that
that's going to happen or should happen
is a definitive statement about
um
what qualifies you to go to a woman's
prison
right right
um you know sport as much as it is
tremendously important is not the most
important thing here sending
um sexual predators to a woman's prison
um because they declare themselves to be
trans is
a an obviously uh grossly unjust thing
to do so um then we have uh to that
point to all of the points
um that the trans ideology is trying to
make inroads in because I agree uh the
the trans women in sports issue is the
most clear-cut at some level right
um even even though
um obviously having men in women's
prisons is a terrible terrible terrible
idea but there are lots of crazy
arguments uh that that you can that you
can make and that have been made whereas
when we're literally talking about
competition and we are sexually
dimorphic species and female
um
categories have been created precisely
because we have always understood that
there that we have different abilities
on average and if we're talking about
Elite athletes then male Elite athletes
will be better than female Elite
athletes in almost every sport and there
may be a couple of sports with that's
not the case like Ultra long distance
running we've talked about this a bit
before but in general no sorry why are
there different categories in the first
place because there are differences and
we're talking about the elite and
therefore the fact that some women are
better at
a lot of things in sport than some men
does not change the fact that we're
talking about Elite athletes
[Music]